en douane bonjour alors qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire de la situation
sur place
mais les opérations de nettoyage ont
commencé plus de 200 tonnes de carburant
ont déjà été récupérés le carburant
ainsi collecté est pour l'instant
stockés sur place et sera évacué dès que
la rivière sera nettoyé une opération
coûteuse en moyens humains et financiers
mais qui ne coûtera pas un rouble
contribuables entendre le dirigeant du
groupe industriel responsable de cette
pollution écoutez nous avons prévu des
réservoirs d'une capacité totale de 16
mille tonnes pour collecter le carburant
celui capacité de 4500 tonnes ont déjà
été fournis et monte sur place nous
avons également préparé des
installations de stockage d'une capacité
de 200 mille tonnes pour collecter le
sol souillé dont nous avons déjà
collecté 7000 tonnes en outre les
travaux de remise en état de cette zone
dont la surface totale est de 6500
mètres carrés sont en cours l'ensemble
de ces activités sera financée par notre
société
nous n'allons pas dépenser un seul
roubles d'argent public le patron de
nordic elle a estimé à plus de 10
milliards de roubles le coût du
nettoyage soit environ 130 millions
d'euros
l'avenir poutine on a profité pour deux
nouveaux sermonné le chef d'entreprise
en lui faisant remarquer que si le
réservoir fautif avait été changée en
temps et en heure il n'aurait pas à
dépenser tout cet argent a coûté si on
l'avait remplacé en temps opportun il
n'aurait pas eu de dégâts
environnementaux et l'entreprise
n'aurait pas eu à en supporter le coût
réfléchissez-y avec attention au sein de
votre entreprise
j'y reviendrai j'espère que l'ensemble
des opérations qui ont été mentionnés
seront menées de manière efficace grâce
aux efforts de tous
alors bien sûr on parle d'importantes
sommes d'argent mais les images le
montrent bien les dommages subis par la
nature eux sont inestimables et afin
d'éviter que de telles catastrophes ne
se répètent vladimir poutine a demandé
une modification de la législation
environnementale chef de l'état russe en
plus ordonné aux autorités compétentes
d'évaluer l'état des installations
similaires à celles de nos risques à
travers tout le pays
reste à espérer que les acteurs
industriels et économiques présents dans
cette région
particulièrement fragile tire les leçons
de cette catastrophe écologique
merci beaucoup antoine pour tous ces
précisions antoine frérot en direct de
moscou